bonjour bonjour cette semaine vous
revenez sur la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon d'instaurer ou de réinstaurer
un service militaire obligatoire
et pour vous c'est un fantasme pourquoi
écouter ya d'abord il faut bien
comprendre ce que dit jean luc mélenchon
il dit deux choses il dit il faut
restaurer le service militaire
obligatoire et il dit en plus dans la
dans la presse polémique autour du
comportement des policiers etc
il faudrait mettre une partie des
conscrits dans la police mais il ya deux
choses
et en fait dans cette déclaration de
mélenchon il ya effectivement pas mal de
chimères d'illusions de fantasmes autour
de ce service militaire obligatoire
d'abord éliminons ce qu'il dit de la
police il laisse entendre que la police
serait violente et raciste et que le
l'intervention des conscrits venus de
toute la population change rsa ce qui
est faux deuxièmement il laisse entendre
que la police est raciste et violente
parce qu'elle est uniformément blanche
et qu'elle n'est pas ouverte aux gens de
l'immigration ce qui est faux au moins
depuis 30 ans donc
éliminons ça arrive on directement au
service militaire obligatoire est là ce
qui est amusant pour la progressiste on
voit que mélenchon n'est pas insensible
à la nostalgie du c'était mieux avant
c'est à dire avant que jacques chirac
président de la république ne supprime
d'un trait de plume le service militaire
obligatoire et on voit bien que ce que
pense mélenchon c'est que ce service
militaire obligatoire permettait
l'intégration de toutes les deux tous
les jeunes français quelle que soit leur
origine ethnique ou sociale
c'est sans doute ce mythe qui est le
plus profondément ancrée dans l'esprit
de beaucoup de gens et en particulier de
la classe politique qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs de gauche mais aussi de
droite mais rétablir un service
militaire ne pourrait-il pas justement
redonner le goût de la discipline à des
jeunes qui en manque singulièrement
aujourd'hui et puis être un creuset
d'intégration même à creuser nationale
alors essayons de voir à quoi servait
d'abord le service militaire obligatoire
auparavant il servait à faire la guerre
ça fait pas à intégrer des gens mais
voyez servait à faire la guerre c'était
le l'enfant de l'appel aux armes de 1792
révolutionnaire l'enfant de la
conscription
donc on faisait la guerre contre
l'allemagne
parce que c'était l'ère des gros
bataillons comme disait napoléon dieu et
du côté des gros bataillons
mais autant après 45 autant de la bombe
atomique et de la paix en europe et des
interventions ouvriers militaire très
professionnaliser en afrique ou ailleurs
le service militaire n'est plus
opérationnel ne sert plus à rien dans le
cadre des guerres d'aujourd'hui première
joie deuxième chose croire qu' il était
le moyen magnifique de l'intégration
avant c'est s'illusionner pour deux
raisons majeures d'abord depuis ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas le service militaire
qui a permis la fusion des deux
jeunesses ennemi avant au 19e siècle
terre la jeunesse catholique d'un côté
la jeunesse bonjour républicaine de
l'autre c'est la guerre de 14 et c'est
la souffrance commune dans les tranchées
en plus depuis des années on tourne on
peut dire au moins depuis les années
soixante dix sept ce service militaire
ne remplit plus ne remplissait plus ce
rôle qu'on lui prête d'intégration et
pour deux raisons majeures d'abord par
le haut c'est à dire que la jeunesse
bourgeoise et estudiantine faisait tout
pour échapper au service militaire pour
se faire réformer ou pour ce faire
comment dire affectés dans les bureaux
dont vous voyez avait toute une partie
de la jeunesse qui ne se mêler plus aux
autres et deuxièmement à partir des
années 80 on a eu le problème de la
jeunesse issue de l'immigration
on a eu un rapport commandé par jean
pierre chevènement le rapport biville
d'un officier tout à fait
dire républicains comme on dit
aujourd'hui et qui a constaté qui a
constaté au grand dam de jean pierre
chevènement et de ses patrons les
problèmes majeurs que posait cette
jeunesse d'origine maghrébine comme on
disait vous savez c'était j aurais je
crois dans le jargon militaire je laisse
d'origine maghrébine qui posait des
problèmes de surdélinquance de repli
dans l'identité musulmane on avait
beaucoup plus parmi cette jeunesse
beaucoup plus de cas d'insoumission doré
vol de rebellions etc et donc les les
officiers supérieurs n'y arrivais plus
et donc ils ont proposé entre autres
pour cette raison mais pas seulement
aussi pour les raisons proprement
militaires que j'ai décrit tout à
l'heure la suppression du service
militaire obligatoire ce café jacques
chirac ce qui n'a pas empêché d'ailleurs
de nombreux jeunes d'origine maghrébine
ou immigrés de s'engager mais
volontairement dans l'armée
donc pour résumer il ya eu une double
fuite
voyez par le haut avec la jeunesse
bourgeoise estudiantine par le bas avec
la jeunesse immigrés donc ce service
militaire obligatoire ne remplissait
plus les fonctions qu'on lui prête
aujourd'hui et même on confond la cause
et la conséquence c'est à dire ce n'est
pas la suppression du service militaire
qui a rendu inopérant le creuset
national français c'est au contraire la
désagrégation du creuset national
français qui a rendue impérative la
suppression du service militaire
obligatoire examen